conçu fabriqué et utilisé en russie le
thé 34 stoppa l'armée allemande et
empêcha la prise de mesures le troisième
reich essaya de clown et le thé 34 mais
ces tentatives n'est galère jamais la
puissance du colosse russe
l'histoire du thé 34 vraiment
remarquable il n'est pas issu d'une
longue expérience des chars il est le
résultat d'un travail acharné au prix
d'efforts inimaginable
le thé 34 points staline le moyen de
montrer que la russie pouvait surclassé
l'ouest militairement et
industriellement et pour c'est un très
très bon cher lorsque les allemands gens
divers ils ont été tus effet
le thé 34 symbolise la lutte
industrielle de la russie contre l'ouest
capitaliste
non seulement le t34 était le meilleur
choix en 1941
mais il conserve à cette suprématie
jusqu'à la fin de la guerre il était
aussi le symbole d'une armée puissante
en 1945 l'armée rouge était la force la
plus efficace pour mener des opérations
blindé de grande envergure
non
la première guerre mondiale avait été
mené de manière très dépassée et la
russie avait en partie permis cette
guerre cause de ce retard technologique
sauf la guerre civile venait entre 17 et
20 ce fut encore qu'il dépassait
camarguais fut menée en grande partie
avec la cavalerie faux mais la pause 1
dans l'écriture mais j'y perds vu qu'une
utilisation de kamel devient prend des
opérations indépendante qui allait être
appelé plus tard l'opération pauvreté
par prochain
la révolution et la guerre civile
convainquirent les bolchéviques qu'il
leur fallait une armée pour rester au
pouvoir
c'est ainsi que naquit en 1918 l'armée
rouge
les guerres civiles est un élément
capital de la création de l'armée
la révolution bolchévique fut
immédiatement suivie de la guerre civile
qui il eut entretien 119 adhérents alors
que la russie avait à faire ton non
seulement à l'opposition blanche mais
aussi à l'hostilité des américains des
britanniques et des japonais les forces
belges sévissent n'était pas
spécialement performant de chute
c'est sous la pression rch qui rase la
quarante mille officiers et
sous-officiers du luart floraux mettre
sur pied une armée rouge professionnels
signalent nc aux locaux dans ce sens la
guerre civile a joué un rôle important
dans le professionnalisme jour de
l'armée rouge
au début des années va le gouvernement
bolchévique balbutiant décida de ses
priorités pour les années à venir
mais lui fallait répondre à de
nombreuses questions comment
ressemblerait une grotte et quels moyens
quels en seraient nécessaires pour y
faire face d'eux les blindés idée a tenu
de l'étendue du pays
lorsque vous avez d'un moyen rapide
fiable sans mobile avec une haute
capacité à opérer très loin de sa blague
alors c'est cette large échange il vous
faudra tel pays mais pour prédire le
futur de la guerre il fallait étudier la
manière dont l'ouest avait mené ses
dires passé les généraux russes anna
l'isère la première guerre mondiale et
en tirèrent des conclusions pour leur
plan de bataille contre la coalition
capitaliste ils l'appelèrent la bataille
profonde
l'offensive russe traditionnel compte
reset a avancé de gros moyens
d'infanterie l'idée de bail profonde
était de réunir le concept de bataille
mécanisée utilisant les blindés
l'infanterie motorisés d'artillerie
mobile et celui de ray profond enfin
c'est sur 50 km de distance avec des
enjeux sont bien m de large et la loi
dassault massif d'infanterie mécanisée à
très longue distance
c'est la version russe du bilan des
raids massif alors compris d'arc
opérante ensemble dans la profondeur du
territoire et nuit le seul problème de
cette doctrine de la bataille profonde
était quelle nécessité un chars lourds
et rapide et en grande quantité
l'industrie russe n'était pas prête à
produire le volume de véhicules et
d'armement requis pour faire de la
bataille profonde une réalité mais cela
allait changer
et le probable
en 1927 staline ans un vaste programme
d'industrialisation et de modernisation
le plan quinquennal il fit
remarquablement ses preuves en
permettant de mettre en place une
industrie lourde en quelques années
malgré le coût humain exorbitant des
délais imposés par staline en 1931 un
programme de production massive de chars
fut lancé la russie allait enfin pouvoir
faire face à l'ouest au début des années
la russie avait mené une transformation
radicale déterminé en finir avec son
image de ruralité paysanne
staline avait lancé à la fin des années
20 un programme d'industrialisation
impitoyable et en 1931 il y avait
suffisamment du sinn prête à produire
des charreaux masse les russes commencer
à penser à la manière dont ils allaient
mettre en oeuvre leurs armes et
mécanisée ex cet univers différents
types de chars qui opérait en relation
étroite avec la flandrie qu'il faut
aussi bien opérer sur la zone de trouve
que mener bien il reste loin derrière la
ligne de but de pelé chez les
britanniques avaient la même idée avec
leurs chants danses ont pris leurs chars
de combat les second exploitant les
percées réalisées par les premiers à
explorer moi je sais cela soit les
russes développer alors qu'il s'agit de
cham 9 4 modèles et on en dise en 1903
il y avait là tant qu est un concept
britannique acheté achard vigueur vous
avez un char léger le terrain sis
également à vie car s'acheter pour
essayer ce char qui allait finalement
joué le rôle de chars d'infanterie
tandis que pour les rênes longue
distance ils développèrent à
charlesbourg monsieur avec le bts
le bt a paru en 1930 lorsque les russes
achetèrent deux chars christie aux états
unis le tt était vraiment une adaptation
russe de la technologie volée c'était
une réalisation de la critique est plus
une voiture blindée cachard ou mais ils
étaient blindées et il avait défini et
des mitrailleuses et n 2 je n'avais pas
donné de bons résultats aux essais de
l'armée américaine qui n'accepte pas les
suspensions christique
contrairement aux autres pays en noir
chez les russes était intéressé en hr 2
comme les américains ne reconnaissait
pas la russie il fallut faire le
transport clandestinement en faisant
passer les chats pour les tracteurs
avant qu'ils ne soient développées en
achat et une minute spex deux pays
sous bien des aspects le btca au russe
ex plutôt moins à certaines unités ce
qu'elle cherchait c'était larmes parfait
pour ce type de manoeuvre est très
mobile il était possible de frapper loin
et très vite et le frapper dur
c'était une arme superbe pour les russes
sans titre on perd pas lorsqu'ils
découvrirent la conception du tout
recommencer à zéro comme et britanniques
ils en gardent des principes
fondamentaux pour la série bt qui était
en quelque sorte un christie sur blindés
et surarmés il allait devenir le modèle
pour tous les chats russe à venir les
concepteurs de l'usiné automobile
kharkov étudièrent le christ y aboutir
au schaerbeek et 7
ce fut l'une des grandes originalités
des années 30
le bt set fut le précurseur du thé 34
avec un équipage de trois hommes il
était armé d'un canon de 45 mm et de
deux mitrailleuses de 7 62 mm protégé
par 22 mm de blindage
son moteur v12 de 500 chevaux le
propulser à 73 km heure avec une
autonomie de 430 km
en 1937 la russie avait subi une
transformation fondamentale c'est énorme
s'il dépasse et la production où est
l'armée rouge avait la plus grosse
forces blindées du monde et elles
étaient dotés du meilleur char de sa
génération mise en oeuvre par une
doctrine d'emploi sophistiqués staline
avait atteint son objectif
je pense que la compétition avec l'ouest
et la mégalomanie furent très important
mais après six ans de tennis man le plus
rapide et le plus efficace était
primordiale au sud et la rue et pas
seulement en matière de matériel
militaire
cela valait pour tous les types de
meilleure facture que ce soit et nous
pas raison pour laquelle les chars
fonctionnaires mieux que les avions et
que vous pouviez construire des charges
très lourdes construire des avions loués
n'était pas une bonne idée
tandis que les chars lourds avec un fort
blindage qu'un grosse puissance de feu
mais permettre au gouvernement
d'atteindre ses objectifs y est donc oui
je pense que les russes ou les
construire le charles plus lourd
explique anne ont le plus gros il ya un
blindage plus épais que n'importe quel
autre chasse c'était pour eux un symbole
cher la puissante voix reste du
socialisme phase économique
mais cet avantage stratégique fut
détruit lorsque staline commence à
suspecter les hauts gradés de son
état-major de projeter un coup d'état
ne pouvant tolérer ne serait ce qu'un
dissident
sa réponse fut rapide et brutale dans ce
qui serait appelé plus tard les purges
staliniennes staline ordonna que tout ce
qu'ils suspectaient le trahison soit
éliminé ou disparaissent rire de farid
marche au dessus c'est ainsi que 3 et 5
maréchaux de l'union se dit wolf man spa
rue et que 75 sa venue 85 généraux un
commandant et autres officiers
supérieurs mené fürth éliminé dans les
12 à 18 mois qui suivirent advance une
relève aux ouvrants forces des deux
échelons commun plus de la moitié des
généraux du division fait assassiner ou
envoyés au goulag ce bike show man en
éliminant de si nombreux chefs à tous
les échelons les niveaux d'entraînement
et le savoir-faire de l'armée rouge
déclinèrent fortement de même que
l'esprit d'initiative
tout le monde avait peur de faire
quelque chose qui contrarie le parti
accepte en fait
les purges coïncidèrent avec la
participation de l'armée rouge à la
guerre civile espagnole où staline
envoyé un certain nombre de bt et d'été
26 pour aider les républicains cette
expérience du combat en espagne acheva
de convaincre les chefs russes qui
s'étaient trop légèrement blindés mais
le blindage n'était pas leur seul
problème il y avait également un sérieux
travail autour des chenilles et des
roues
c'est un concept intéressant car il est
à la fois des roues et des funny cela
peut paraître démodé à l'heure actuelle
mais l épopée la technologie de jeudi
s'était pas encore parfaitement au point
où elle n'était pas superflu même de
faire le chemin jusqu'aux combats seront
pour ensuite monter des fumis en moins
de 30 minutes
le débat entre rouen et chenilles pris
brusquement fin l'hiver 1939 lorsque
l'union soviétique envahit la finlande
face à la résistance acharnée des sinois
il devint évident que les chars de
l'époque n'était pas assez blindés ou
armées mais les concepteurs du bt qui
est convaincu qu'avec des chenilles
celui ci pourrait être sur blindes et
surarmés sans perte de performance cette
nouvelle version du btph eu dénommé t34
en hommage à l'année 1934 année du
décret décide en expansion massive des
forces blindées se lier deux prototypes
étaient pris en janvier 1940 la
production de masse débutent en juin et
le 1er 34 enfants service septembre de
la même année
le thé 34 et il a des chars les plus
extraordinaires de la seconde guerre
mondiale il était dirigé par un équipage
de cinq hommes armés d'un canon de 76 mm
ainsi que de deux mitrailleuses de 7 62
mm
son moteur diesel v de développer 4 193
chevaux et le propulse à une vitesse de
50 km heure avec une hauteur de 1300 km
au moment de son entrée en service il
est certain qu'au cas sharon se comparer
au titre en carrière tout le monde était
ébahi par la manière dont ce chan avait
été conçu il était tout simplement
parfait québec entre construire chars on
doit obligatoirement faire des compromis
abrite le soit la vitesse le blindage
chacun de ces paramètres interfère avec
les zones les charpentiers est un
compromis de tout cela
le thé 34 connu son baptême du feu en
juin 1941 lorsque hitler rompu son pacte
de non-agression avec staline et déclara
la guerre lino ce biais lors de ce qui
eut pour nom de code opération
barbarossa trois millions de soldats
allemands franchir la frontière entre
l'allemagne et la russie
cette armée fut divisée en trois groupes
un groupe non impuissante et un groupe
sud
le groupe nord devait prendre leningrad
le groupe centre devait fondre sur
moscou tandis que le groupe sud étaient
censés occuper l'ukraine
sur le papier les ressources soviétique
semblé fantastique avec 21000 sharp
paréo 3300 chars allemands et rien
n'aurait pu préparer l'armée allemande e
t 34 après une série de victoires en
europe les tankistes allemands avaient
l'habitude en france et facilement toute
résistance blindé le t34 un effet
dévastateur auto 27 et fantassins dans
le groupe nord
coût du chariot sur touché par le canon
antichar pas et un canot s'est elle est
canon scié chat en dotation dans
l'infanterie nous avions de 75 mm 1
canaux locaux capables de percer les
blindages
vous ne pouvez rien faire contre un tank
avec un armement classique et en autant
qu'ils étaient bien trop protégé c'est
la raison pour laquelle le thé 34 était
le meilleur char russe
l'armée allemande découvrit avec horreur
que le thé 34 étaient quasiment
résistant à tous les obus
la raison était simple leur blindage
était incliné des forces du thé 34 était
sa superstructure blindés aux parois
incliné ucia concept de repris ensuite
par toutes les autres armes et le
principe réside dans le fait que cela
augmente la protection tout en
conservant le même bois francs c'était
simple mais les russes il y avait pensé
en premier
il était doté d'un épais blada 10 et la
puissance canon de 76mm lorsque les
allons découvrir sur les champs de
bataille il surclasse à tous qu'ils
avaient leurs 37 mm le prouve et supplie
à la comparaison et leurs 50 millimètres
avaient déjà des problèmes
le 88 me laisse pouvait rivaliser avec
76 mm mais le charme est capable de
l'emporter et est gros il constituait
une tête piquée de 76 mm pouvait
l'affronter sans eau distance de combat
dans certains affrontements
seule la lutte entre le quai 34 86 mm et
est loin d'être évidente d'une brouille
les allemands dû prouver une solution
qui serait rapidement réglée
atterrés les équipages des penseurs 3 et
qu'un se rendirent compte que leur
canonnier incapable de percer le
blindage du thé 34 hors jeu parfois il y
avait également un 75e
il l'appelait le destructeur et choque
c'est comme ça en club car nous étions
inférieurs aux russes pour ce qui
concernait les chars sont allés et elle
avait le légendaire t34 une arme tout à
fait différente
les rues sur de sérieux problèmes au
début de l'opération barbarossa il avait
l'excellente et 34 mais en trop petit
nombre pour être concentrés dans la
bataille
le thé 34 pose un problème tactique à
l'armée d'hitler mais l'entraînement de
l'armée allemande et sa doctrine
d'emploi lui permirent de surmonter cet
inconvénient
en 1941 les soviétiques payèrent le prix
des purges staliniennes
car les soldats en service dans l'armée
rouge manquais d'entraînement et n'avait
pas l'expérience du terrain il était
courant qu'un soldat partent au combat
avec seulement une heure de formation
sur un chat
kinetic liste il faut mois six ans
entraînement intensif pour faire son
travail correctement
staline avait éliminé des centaines
d'officiers de haut rang abri c'est
horrible purges staliniennes éliminé à
35 mille officiers et généraux au coach
jugés sommairement exécutés ce qui prive
à l'armée rouge de ces fausses tous ont
été tués sans aucune forme de procès
c'est bien sûr sera peut-être juste
sortir d'une guerre civile longue avec
la russie se trouvant dans une situation
très difficile
force principalement il y avait un
manque d'entraînement léger cuba il
avait été prélevé au sein de
l'infanterie médias cavalerie avec un
grognement semaine at ce que même que
les 6 subalternes qui apprenaient leur
métier sur le tas rohan marley vaucluse
où le vernet sur les premiers des 30
joueurs show est menée et les critères
qu'il faut de la visibilité très limitée
en particulier les jeunes actuels un
spectacle une amélioration les banques
ont cité des images
m
la communication sein de l'armée rouge
est épouvantable beaucoup de soldats
étaient illettrés
il y avait un manque cruel de radio
pendant le commandement presque
impossible et bitumer chars allemands
avaient des radios tous les chars
américains avaient des radios et 1941
seuls les chars de commandement de
l'armée rouge avait des radios et les
chefs de ce loto devait faire des
signaux avec un drapeau quand on se met
leur hausse ce qui n'était vraiment pas
une bonne idée au milieu d'un combat de
chars ces prix fort ou alors les charges
qu'il est simplement hochart de tête à
dire ce qui ne permettait pas de
réaliser des tactiques complexe
en octobre le groupe centre était à 25
km de moscou
mais à mesure que le temps se dégrade et
les chenilles des chars allemands durant
l'été avec la boue et plus tard avec la
neige le t34 lui avec les suspensions du
christie ses larges chenilles et sa
faible pression sol rester mobile encore
une fois les ingénieurs soviétiques
avaient trouvé là constat est simple à
l'efficacité incontestable
l'un des problèmes récurrents avec les
chats réside dans les goupilles des
maillons de chenilles la goupille est
tout simplement un axe en afrique et
maintient deux maillons ensemble et la
difficulté de la faire tenir en place
les russes de mettre une plaque incurvé
sur l'intérieur de l'avenir ce qui
faisait que tout pays qui seraient
sortis à mi-course données et rabattu en
position normale par cette pièce
alors que l'hiver commençait à ralentir
l'armée allemande les équipages russes
pour apprécier leurs chars conçus pour
résister à un climat extrême son moteur
v12 utiliser un diesel qui je les
entends paiera tueur inférieur à
l'essence utilisée par les chars
allemands
il n'y avait pas besoin d'allumer un feu
sous le 34 pour pouvoir démarrer son
moteur la température descend dit à moi
56° 7e et les allemands n'est absolument
pas préparé un combat hivernale absolue
en plein concert des nations
elle n'avait pas de liquide antigel par
décret c' antigel crise sans que leurs
armes continuent à fonctionner est face
à une cascade stack
on a sans doute été pris dans la glace
que l'on rencontre des femmes au score
ce qui s'était très bien adaptée au
combat en hiver en particulier grâce à
ses phénix d'après larouche faut
comparer à celles d'autres véhicules de
la même génération
les aliments jeu pour affronter la neige
dure adapté des sur chenille élargie
mais elle n'était pas très efficace et
assez facilement le 34 ne pouvait
pousser sur la neige sans difficulté la
suspension christie's t34 ne cassez pas
sur scène et sur la glace aussi
facilement que le train de roulement ce
haro multiple égal est de retour
richard allemands qui eux est assez
vulnérable de même le moteur se
comportaient admirablement par grand
froid
c'était un très bon moteur et les
allemands avaient bien plus de
difficultés à maintenir les performances
de leurs engins
le thé 34 avait évidemment été conçu
pour le terrain sur lequel il c'est à
dire la russie avec s'était construit
d'après l'expérience russe et les normes
standards des conditions quotidiennes en
russie était à la base de tous les
allemands avaient suivi la même démarche
pour leurs chars mais l'allemagne
n'était définitivement pas la russie
bien que l'infernal hiver russe
ralentissait les allemands le temps
allait finir par manquer soviétique
il n'y aurait pas de victoire cinglante
des allemands mais ils finiraient par
gagner après un long combat d'usure le
plus petit lob sur l'épreuve d'autant
plus de génie tactique
après avoir subi des pertes
catastrophiques en 1941 l'armée rouge
devait se rééquiper seraient entraînés
pour le printemps 40 de la seule manière
dont l'union soviétique pouvait battre
les forces de l' axe nécessitait
beaucoup plus de thé 34
mais il y avait un problème la plupart
des usines russes se trouvaient dans la
zone prises par les allemands leningrad
et est un point clé de la production des
chars russes et elle était déjà encerclé
par les allemands
fin 1941 staline imaginales à pensable
et entrepris dès délocaliser l'industrie
militaire soviétique à l'est de l'oural
et de la volga en sibérie orientale et
en asie centrale
les usines que réassembler dans les
mêmes conditions incroyables que l'heure
du plan quinquennal mais à une échelle
jamais vue auparavant
ce déplacement de l'industrie je crois
tu ne fut pas un succès total
mais ce procès que sa section mais c'est
un fait historique sans précédent que de
déplacer à me près de 2500 usine
géographique sur une distance
équivalente à celle séparant le sud de
l'angleterre face à l'islande et avec
une interruption minimes de la
production en termes de production de
chars et de pièces d'artillerie au
christ est dit on a pu observer une
progression lente mais constante tout au
long de 1942 1943 et 10 à 40 cas alors
que le thé 34 surclassé de loin les
chars allemands les soviétiques
n'avaient pas à développer de nouveaux
modèles et alors que les allemands se
démener pour concevoir arrive à noter 34
les russes eux se concentrèrent sur la
production au bois en attendant que les
ingénieurs allemands construisent un
nouveau char
le haut commandement allemand ne
s'attendait certes pas ému aussi durée
aussi longue
lorsqu'il ordonne à l'invasion d'un
récit en 1941 il ne croyait pas les
russes capable de construire un char
opérationnelle et une série de victoires
en europe en force à la fois d'hitler
dans l'investissement lité du troisième
reich
au début de l'opération barbarossa il
n'était pas question de remplacer le
panshir 4 cheval de bataille de l'armée
allemande
mais le t34 avait brisé le mythe de
l'infériorité soviétique
les allemands avaient désespérément
besoin d'un chat capable au moins
d'égalé si l'on de battre le terrain car
bien qu'il ne fût pas acceptable
politiquement de copier 34
c'est en fin de compte ce que le firent
les allemands leur répond sur le pan de
5,5 et de mes panthères qui se
rapprochait le plus du tiers 34 100
canons de 75 mm son épée blindage
incliné on faisait un adversaire
particulièrement dangereux les allemands
attendent ils étaient 43 pour lancer la
nouvelle arme
tu es tu le rendre 11 juin 1941 et l'été
1943 les allemands firent chose qu'ils
purent pour égaler les russes en termes
de qualité silence de quantité
essayèrent de produire des chars aussi
bon que l'été 34 et le calvez ils
construisirent ainsi le tigre sans
obtenir le même type de blindage que le
kavé avec un canon capable de percer
aussi bien celui du t 34 que celui du
kavé c'était 97 à auzits lahssini salle
idéale pour détruire les chars
ils développèrent un autre char qui
n'était pas un clone du terrain de
capter des fous est à charge c'est
encore les mêmes sa tribune
il avait un blindage incliné à canon de
75 mm ce fut le pont terre dont le
penseur et ici on peut dire la version
allemande de chez une grande case il
était beaucoup plus lourd il faut fait
que penser aussi l'autre le kavé et ceux
qui on faisait un char assez imposant
mais ses performances et exhalant sinon
meilleur que sa petite et de 34
après la défaite allemande à saly gras
durant l'hiver 42-43 une énorme saillie
dans la ligne de front large de 160km au
fonds de 110 km était centré sur la
ville de course
ignorant l'avis de ses généraux qui lui
conseillait de rester temporairement sur
la défensive
hitler décida de reprendre l'initiative
en écrasant la poche de koursk
mais un proche avait prévenu les russes
qu'ils suspectaient déjà une attaque
dirigée contre la ville de course
l'armée rouge transforme alors la ville
en une énorme forteresse dans laquelle
les forces allemandes seraient canaliser
vers les couloirs des qui en russe par
des chants de ville soigneusement placés
lorsque tous les préparatifs pour
achever un million de 336 mille soldats
russes avec 3444 chat donc une majorité
de tes 34 sur place et dans ou derrière
hui cercle concentrique défensif est
allé sur une distance de 175 km bien que
les allemandes et déployer que 900 mille
hommes et 2700 véhicules blindés
il avait confiance dans leur nouveau
char tigre et panthère en compense l
avantage numérique des russes
mais la course l'armée allemande
rencontrent les mêmes problèmes que ceux
l'armée rouge des bus 41 le manque
d'entraînement des équipages est là mais
cela n'allait pas attendre et poney ces
nouveaux champs qui naturellement venue
des chefs de produit les équipes à
s'entraîner correctement et les charges
mais pas celui ci vise à mende et c'est
arrivé sur le champ de bataille les
sharks tomber enceinte située avant le
son est reparti après accouplement
gasoil et jean riou condensé newman ça
il y avait des chars on passe partout
vous regardiez qu'elle n'avait pas été
assez est pourtant souvent des chats
sont surchauffés ans où les véhicules
carburant son annexe en mettant le feu
au chan kim parfois exploser carrément
et que la phase parti c'est de nouveau
chat le tir était un peu plus fiable car
les v10 son aspect plutôt faste où elle
restait méconnu des équipages
l'offensive allemande fut lancée le 5
juillet rencontre à une résistance
remarquablement coriace la profondeur
des défenses soviétique ne permit pas
aux allemands de réaliser les percées
qu'il voulait
mais à koursk l'armée vous je découvris
que le thé 34 n'avait dorénavant plus la
haute main sur les combats de chars
est-ce que cette théorie de constater
que les allemands avaient les meilleurs
chats rats comme les soviétiques avaient
le courage d'une hausse ils avaient
déployé leurs charges en arche de
grosses équipes ne nous prouve l obscur
et il avait des chefs de chars aguerris
que gilles avait des chefs de division
et des chefs de corps expérimentés y
tient pas trop il était réellement gagné
une bataille majeure contre la wehrmacht
en été
la soie de base c'est pourquoi cette
bataille réellement important car à
moscou en 41 ou à stalingrad en 1942
la bataille avait été menée en hiver et
de ce furent des batailles d'infanterie
dont des combats de chars mais à course
en 1943 ce fut une bataille blindés et
les russes pour gagner cette bataille à
celles qui suivent il repoussèrent les
allemands ce cri prouva qu'il était
capable de mener à condren moderne frais
et ce qui marqua le début de l'ère de
l'armée rouge
le principal défaut du thé 34 était son
canon de 76 mm qui n'arrivait pas à
percer les blindages frontaux du tigre
et du panthères à moi d'être à une
distance dangereusement proches
le thé 34 avait essentiellement besoin
d'un cadre plus gros
en août 1943 des travaux commencèrent
pour améliorer sensiblement de thé 34 et
en faire un engin de combat viable après
que les changements nécessaires a été
réalisé le nouveau chars entrent en
production en janvier 1944 le char à 6
obtenue fut dénommé t 34 85
il embarque un équipage de cinq hommes
il tirait son nom de son canon de 85 mm
il était également armé de deux
mitrailleuses de 7,62 avec son blindage
de 90 mm il était propulsé par
l'efficace moteur v12 de 500 chevaux
puis lui conférer une autonomie de 300
km ils pouvaient atteindre une vitesse
maxi sur route de 50 km le thé 34,85 est
essentiellement un thé 34 dont on aurait
droit mais tous les défauts lasours elle
était largement meilleur que la
précédente version 3 hors jeu pouvait
maintenant s'ils travaillaient
confortablement
il était débarrassé de ces racailles bus
sont canons étaient meilleures et son
blindage en plus épais malgré cela où il
était presque si rapide que le thé 34 76
et lorsqu'il apparut sur les champs de
bataille
il était le chat le plus puissante et le
monde chante cause un choc aux alliés
lorsqu'il le découvrir
le nouveau canon de 85 mm avait plus de
1000 mètres de portée pratique et
pouvaient pénétrer le blindage frontale
du pente est raide utile
l'un des avantages du thé 34,85 résider
dans sa conception qui n'a cliquez pas
le long processus qui avait compliqué la
production du peintre allemand
autre avantage ils pouvaient être
construit sur les mêmes chaînes de
production que le thé 34,76 il allait
bientôt être produits dans d'aussi
grande quantité que son prédécesseur
en 1944 onze mille t 34 85 étaient en
service soit deux fois et demi le nombre
d'exemplaires de son rival de panthère
le premier thé 34 85 entre en service au
sein de la 1ère armée de la garde effet
accueilli par ses équipages comme achard
qu'ils pouvaient tenir son rang face aux
tirs et aux panthères lorsque les
opérations offensives repris en 1944 la
nouvelle génération d'équipage aguerris
et des machines moderniser infligèrent
de sérieuse défaite à l'armée allemande
lors de l'opération bas gracieux en juin
44 l'infanterie soviétique les chars
lourds ouvert une brèche à travers la
défense allemande qui fut exploité par
le nouveautés 34 puis efficace et agile
à la fin juillet les chars soviétiques
avaient atteint la vistule et les portes
de varsovie magra surmontera jusqu'où
l'armée rouge j'étais arrivé en termes
de commandement d'aptitude au combat
équipements ce fut l'une des opérations
les plus longues et sophistiqué de toute
la guerre les efforts de l'été avait
tendu les chaînes logistiques à
l'extrême et les opérations à grande
échelle n'allait pas reprendre avant
janvier 1945
mais le 16 avril de cette année l'armée
rouge avait atteint les alentours de
berlin un mélange de troupes régulières
de vétérans de jeunesses hitlériennes
défendez chaque plus chaque maison pièce
par pièce
l'existence d'engagements rapprocher la
marge de manoeuvre limitée rentes et les
chats retour très vulnérables face aux
défenses armés de lance roquettes et de
canons antichars de mines et de
cocktails molotov
plus de 800 chars vue sur perdu dans ces
féroces combats
mais malgré la résistance fanatiques des
allemands les soviétiques prirent le
reich tacle 30 avril et hitler se
suicidant le même jour la ville se
rendit le 2 mai les troupes allemandes
déposer les armes le 7
le soviétique avait réussi un équilibre
parfait entre protection puissance de
feu et mobilité avec le thé 34 c'était
un hybride des meilleurs concepts
technologiques du monde entier les paons
staline c'était le symbole de la volonté
de la mère russie de vaincre l'ouest
capitaliste à la fois industriel man u
militairement et pourtant est très
curieusement il garda une
caractéristique qui symbolise le
capitalisme lui même un aspect amusant a
proposé caractéristiques du thé 34,85
qu'il manqua pas d'interpeller le sens
de l'humour des allemands il résidait
dans l'apparence d'un rap arrière qui
une fois ouverte rechange et des
oreilles de mickey
ce qui est ironique quand on sait que
mickey mouse est un symbole du
capitalisme présent sur une icône du
communisme un contraste [__] mais
jean-louis staline savait que la seule
manière de battre le troisième reich
était de produire les thés 34 en masse
il savait aussi que pour garder un taux
de production élevés il fallait que le
concept soit simple et c'est la
simplicité du thé 34 qui permis de
repousser l'envahisseur nazi
son design rasta globalement le même
tout au long de la guerre il pouvait
détruire la plupart des charges adverses
il était rapide bien protégés et facile
à entretenir les ingénieurs allemands
cherchèrent à éviter le thé 34 mais
toutes leurs tentatives échouèrent d'une
manière catastrophique produits de
l'industrie colossal le t34 été
l'instrument qui avait écrasé l'armée
allemand il mérite à ce titre d'être
considéré comme l'un des plus grands
chars du 20e siècle
au nom de peste et 34 n'était pas le
meilleur char en termes d'ingénierie et
de performance mais c'était le charles
du polyvalent de toute la guette
il a délibérément été conçu pour être
produit en masse et les russes en ont
produit plus de 55000 toutes versions
confondues sur toute la durée de la
guerre il était facile à mettre en
oeuvre et il le fut essentiellement par
des paysans certaines pièces étaient
interchangeables avec la plupart des
autres charges
vous aviez besoin d'un autre moteur du
que vous deviez prendre celui la cave et
si vous aviez besoin d'une vieillesse
quelconque et que vous pouviez les
prendre d'un tas d'autres véhicules
le tilt et 34 on s'était pas le meilleur
char de la guerre pauline mais au regard
de ce qu'il a accompli pendant cette
guerre ce fut le char le plus efficace
du conflit